hey youtubers is Charlie happy Father's
Day what a great day to talk about
bastards on Game of Thrones we have
battle of the bastards coming tonight so
I'm gonna talk all about bastards in
Game of Thrones just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far
the idea of bastards what makes a
bastard is actually pretty simple a
bastard is any child born out of wedlock
so it doesn't matter if your father was
a prince
if your mother was Lyanna stark or if
your father's hot pie a bastard is still
a bastard but not all bastards are
created equal as we know people with
Kings blood bastards with Kings blood
much more magical than regular bastards
the other common denominator uniting all
bastards is that they're not allowed to
inherit property from their father
unless there is no one else in the line
of succession so a lot of you are asking
does that mean that Gendry could ascend
to the Iron Throne
given that Tommen is an illegitimate
child technically yes but they would
probably be open revolt in the streets
in the other Nobles of the realm might
not support it so they might bring arms
against the crown Paris actually said
this really important thing when he was
telling Tyrion about the Targaryen
restoration this grand new purpose
trying to put Daenerys on the throne he
said that a good leader would be someone
with a good name in someone who the
people would love so the big problem
Gendry has is one of awareness people
don't really know he exists so if he
were to surface and say I'm Robert's
bastard they would be years and years of
deliberation that would probably descend
into another Civil War
so bastards can be very important and
I'll talk about the Blackfyre rebellion
in a little bit which was a giant
Targaryen bastard rebellion so here all
the bastards for the realm in the crown
lands any bastards even royal bastards
are called waters in Dorne the called
sand like the sand snakes in the Iron
Islands they're called pike in the north
they're all called snow like Jon Snow
Ramsay snow in the reach they'll call
flowers in the Riverlands they're called
rivers in the Stormlands that are called
storm like heed Rick's storm from the
books who was cut out by the show in the
Vale they're called stone and in the
westerland's they're called Hill so if
you really wanted to get technical
Tommen's last name would be hill but
there are one or two ways that you can
get a different last name as a bastard
so one it depends on who your father is
- it depends on where you're born so the
father typically has naming rights so
Ned Stark
Discover's r plus l equals j sees John
snow
he's born near Dorn so you could call
him sand if he wanted to but because
he's born to a Targaryen who lives in
the Crown lands you could call him
waters if he wanted to but Ned Stark
obviously takes him in and passes him
off as his own bastard and he's from the
north so he calls him snow so John snow
could have had one of any three last
names unless he'd been legitimized and
would have gotten the Targaryen name so
how do bastards get legitimized Ramsay
snow was legitimized now he's Ramsay
Bolton that can only be done by royal
decree so Roose Bolton at the end of
season four got a royal decree from the
crown to name Ramsay his legitimate heir
so Ramsay would then be able to go
around calling himself Ramsay Bolton but
here's a really interesting idea if Jon
Snow is the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark why did Rhaegar not
legitimize Jon Snow immediately why
didn't he prepare for that well one of
the problems with that is that he would
have had to go to the Mad King to get
that royal decree and the Mad King was
genuinely insane and embroiled in a
giant civil war so if Jon Snow is one of
the two who may have been promised by a
prophecy it's important to keep them
secret so even if Rhaegar Targaryen had
survived the Battle of the Trident
Robert hadn't killed him he might have
tried to keep Jon Snow on the DL but Jon
Snow isn't the only famous bastard in
history of Westeros a lot of you have
heard of the Blackfyre rebellion
Blackfyre is a name with multiple
meanings
so one it's the name of house Blackfyre
that was started by daemon Blackfyre one
of the many bastards of Aegon the fourth
Blackfyre is also the name of the
ancestral Valyrian blade that originally
belonged to Aegon the conquerer that was
passed down as a sign of the right to
rule so what would happen is is when an
old Targaryen king was getting ready to
die or he selected a new candidate for
successor like if he had multiple sons
but he felt one son was better than the
other four succeeding him he would
bestow on them black fire and that would
be the outgoing King's way of telling
the realm this is your new king bow to
him
so black fire bastard rebellion things
get really nasty when a king has a lot
of bastards Robert had a lot in common
with this situation wherein he had many
many bastards but Joffrey and Cersei
moved to suppress most of them so most
but not all of Robert's bastards were
killed
Aegon the fourth had many
bastards that he legitimized on his
deathbed which is a big problem because
you throw a whole bunch of people with a
lot of followers in a lot of support
into the line of succession so a lot of
Aegon's bastards became very popular one
of the most famous ones that we've
actually met on the show is the
three-eyed Raven his real name is
Brendan rivers but that's because he
comes from the Riverlands Aegon the
fourth had many different bastards in
many different parts of the realms so
not all of them had the same last name
but what happened is is on his deathbed
as he legitimized all these people he
had given the sword black fire to one of
his bastards daemon Blackfyre instead of
his legitimate son so you can see the
problem it causes this giant war where
demons like I have the right to rule it
doesn't matter if I'm a bastard I'm
still the one destined to sit on the
Iron Throne so you have a big war the
black fires are defeated and then the
sword black fire gets carried over to
the east with Damon's successors so
there is a Targaryen ancestral blade out
there somewhere that technically belongs
to Daenerys it'd be amazing if the show
surface did but I'm not expecting it but
tonight's episode battle of the bastards
is very important for a number of
different reasons it's going to be the
most amazing episode ever it's the only
episode this year that HBO has submitted
for an Emmy and I think both the writing
and directing categories multiple
different categories
typically episodes get submitted for
Emmys in a single category like Best
Director or best makeup or best writing
this is one of the only episodes that
HBO submitted for multiple like the
really big marquee Emmys so as you can
imagine
HBO feels like this is probably the
strongest episode of the season in as
such there will be a couple different
storylines so I'm hoping they touch on
Jon Snow's parentage without fully
explaining it I'm expecting them to save
a little something for the finale I
believe that the actor who plays young
Ned Stark is going to be in the finale
so there'll be at least one more brand
flashback before the end of the season
hopefully resolving the Tower of joy
reveal that would be a great reveal to
go out on going into season seven like
oh my god and I know a lot of you are
wondering is he gonna pull multiple
babies out of the tower so I still
believe R plus L equals J but just keep
your mind open there could be any number
of interpretations or changes that the
show makes although this is one of the
things that feels like the show would
try to be very true to the books like
Georgia our Martin would have helped
them with this big reveal it almost
feels like too big of a WTF reveal for
the show to completely change the Jon
Snow reveal from the books so let me
know in the comments who is your
favorite bastard on Game of Thrones and
what you guys think about that quick
reminder there's a new round of the
giveaway that's going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
I'll remind everyone when I post my
episode 9 video tonight so get hype and
Happy Father's Day isn't it great that
we got to celebrate Mother's Day and
Father's Day in the same season of Game
of Thrones well you guys wait for my
video to post tonight you can click here
for an hour plus l equals je tower of
joy refresher and you can click here for
my episode 8 video thank you so much for
watching everybody looks like five I'll
see you guys tonight
you